he is Christopher mad dog Russo how are
you Christopher good afternoon Richard I
would say Pat okay well how do you take
this news of Dolan no surprised it
surprised me I you know maybe the
Clemente old thing with a buyout maybe
presentist scared the hell out of Dolan
who knows they did allow Phil to work
through the draft so I mean to let him
go four days before free maybe that has
something to do with it did free
but the next one of any money anyway no
free agents coming here anyway so I I
don't know why the urgency now again
maybe Anthony you know he's always had a
soft spot Dolan for Anthony I might have
lose something to do with it maybe all
the the background noise got a little
something to do with it maybe they were
the next were alarmed that the
Persinger's thing was a possibility but
most Nick fans
I shouldn't say most all Nick fans at
least in this quarter richer rejoicing
you know they look at Jackson as a
failed experiment
despite porzingis maybe the kid they're
getting a draft from france is going to
be good but the Nick fan right now
doesn't worry about that you know Phil
was aloof Phil you know was in a lot of
people thought he was kind of sleeping
on a job whether he was sleeping in
Subway's or at NFL Draft things as we
all heard about him not north the record
obviously speaks for itself you know he
didn't have that consistent plan
he tried last year with rose and and
Noah that didn't work out Noah's a
disastrous contract rose to be out of
there too so I think most Knick fans are
rejoicing they don't like Dolan they
hate him too
but I think they realized the end was
near but I did poke people Spri I'm
surprised because the last time I heard
from Dolan is in the early spring he
said he was committed to the five years
for Jackson and he jettisons the matter
the day after three so I think a lot of
people in New York are surprised today I
think Chris this is nothing but a
porzingis rescue project that that
basically is a realization of the
special kid that Phil had dropped in his
lap and was wise enough to draft let's
give him credit on that credit for that
but if because if he is going to go in a
free agency period with the idea of
trading
him for somebody or trying to get rid of
Carmelo right at the outset of the free
agency period by asking Dolan to pay
pony up another 60 million dollars into
the kitty to paint him off I think that
that that had to be a nation penitent
denomination I think you probably right
on that I think that combo
you know the giving card they should
never resign criminal anyway and then
they made it worse for the no trade but
you know in the Knicks are not ready to
win when they reassigned him a couple of
years ago
Carmelo wants to stay in New York he's
more interested in you know being in the
Big Apple it will all those little
things he does more so that he is on
winning a championship let's say hand
him a championship and put him on the
Cavaliers and pay him 30 million a year
he's not going so he's not interested in
doing that he wants to stay here the
next game on that big Jackson game that
big contract which I at the time this is
not a second guess first guess I said is
stupid and you know that's one of them
and I think you're right i think the
presentist thing is a factor I think
maybe they were a little nervous they
trade him he is the real deal as you
said rich you right on he is the future
the franchise the fans love them I don't
get that the Celtics are gonna give him
3,000 pieces alright that's one thing
they weren't going to go that far but I
think I think the next I think Dolan got
nervous to the Nixon on good hands and
he was a little nervous of what Jackson
could do it you know and you know was
the way he was reacting so he said I'll
get him the heck out of here give him 25
million dollars to leave all that Steve
Mills running for a while with the
sidewalk will do with the basketball
official down the road
hornacek now obviously I don't know if
this is good or bad for him it's bad
that you know Jackson the guy who hired
him is leaving all this history he's got
to be history Chris angle offensive he
does want to play it where you go you
Chris Mad Dog Russo here with me this is
what the Knicks should do and I know
that they're looking at they're looking
at the current general manager of the
Toronto Raptors right now according to
Daily News that Masai Ujiri I believe
I'm pronouncing his name correctly yep
because they're looking at him although
he's under contract they'd have to
they'd have to flip something to the
Raptors to go get him or need permission
to go get him short of that you got the
guy who's been the architect of the Cavs
and I know you know it's easy to have
LeBron James trying to build around
him but go go get the general manager
David Griffin who just got hired in
Cleveland fry and go and go and go and
go go find go find the next Brad Stevens
and all that IO that I agree with ya go
get yourself with college coach yeah
who's young and into it yes and ready to
go I liked hornacek he's been dealing
with a tough deck but you're not gonna
I'm not going to worry about one a
second to go get a I don't know who that
coach should be any in college Stevens
is perfect what a higher by Ainge he's a
great great coach that's not a bad idea
another Nixon I ready to win right now
so I don't think I have to do it this
minute but that's not a bad point I'm
not you know you want to give one a
second year to see what you can do and
he doesn't have Jackson looking over his
shoulder I guess you could do it that
way as well
but you're right rich you got the right
idea and here a big Knicks fan I know
that's way way back you got the right
idea maybe and maybe Jackson would have
left you a good player here with the
French kid maybe he's going to be a good
player maybe so although the the
Frederic rice memory of the French
pastry from that to Stubb I what a
disaster sticks it still sticks in my
craw the French pastry as Frederick vice
was known as well but we shouldn't paint
all people from France with the same
brush plus if I present gainst the
European player they drafted to you so
he said to be very good yeah kind of
washed out off with lice but you're
right you got to hope this kids a good
player so they don't knows you have no
idea so Carmelo stays porzingis stays
and then you try and reshape this best
you can so what why does it work for the
Rangers under Dolan and it doesn't for
the Knicks can you tell me that I never
took the Rangers seven years under satyr
before they finally put something
together now you know the Knicks the
Rangers were to make applause for a long
long time and then you know they tried
to do the the highfalutin free agent and
they tried the other way you know they
really had trouble finding that right
mix and then you know they landed and
got the right players and they built a
team about lonk wish they got good
defenseman and away you go and the
Rangers have been very consistent and
won the whole thing but they have into a
cup final they've been to a couple of
conference finals they've done it
they've won a team right and don't let
has stayed out of it and you know he
gave sailor a long leash but Seder was
not a mess off the ice you know
I mean you know Jackson's been a mess
he's picking fights with Anthony he's
picking fights with porzingis he's been
very cryptic with his tweets he falls
asleep in certain scenarios the Knicks
much more attention Nick which you know
that been anybody on the Knicks and it
is on the range more people pay
attention the Knicks in New York than
the Rangers the Rangers sort of operate
in you know by their lonesome the Knicks
pipeline by contrast or a franchise that
everybody pays attention to
they're a big team in the NBA the range
is sort of our - but it's hockey so
you're not as out there as you're still
so if you make a mistake here you know
you're on a limb that's got a little
something to do the - compared to say -
who was here for a long time before they
won but again most Knick fans and you
said I know you're one and you're
rejoicing I think most Knick fans
despite the fact that they don't like
Dolan either most Knick fans seem to
think that this is a positive
development today well I know people
think that I know you only got a couple
minutes but I mean I'm not rejoicing as
I said at the top of the show and I Kris
it's just it's it's sad man I mean this
is one of red Holtzman's finest and and
watching him win with Jordan and Shaq
and Kobe was tough while the Knicks were
trying to bang their heads against the
Jordan years and couldn't break through
and then in watching him win with the
Lakers and then he finally comes back to
the Knicks and we all had that sense as
Knicks fans deep in our pit of our
stomach thing that's not going to work
out because it's don't linens just the
Knicks and and and and it's come true
the prophecy came like spot-on true and
I am just bummed about it yeah I need
blame Doland forgiven him the five years
it was the right game a shot was the guy
out there that had a great track record
the first I tell you the Anthony's
signing was a big mistake aid cause he
doesn't like Anthony doesn't like the
Anthony game the bull sticks to Anthony
we all know that and you know Andy
doesn't make anybody around him better
and you know he's a great closer but
doesn't make anybody around him better I
think Jackson realized that it's against
his best thought to get him signed but
he did and I think that was the
beginning of the end I can't kill him
last year everybody in New York wanted
him to make the duros shade is not a bad
trade
don't have to make a big commitment to
him Noah 72 million dollars was stupid
he was shot
the Bulls knew it and he grabbed him
money is no object with the Knicks so he
didn't really care about that but it
killed his cap that was a mistake and he
was a mistake his antics were a mistake
the cryptic messages and the fact he was
aloof never was available for the media
was a mistake you know going through
Charley Rosen you know his little buddy
there and you know getting all the
information out of him was a mistake and
listen it was a dark cloud I don't think
it's been lifted rich and you're right
it is a little sad he's an ex Nick
people don't realize that he was a great
wasn't a great Nick but it was an
important it was great Holtzman came
those done and it's a big blow for the
next day but I think overall most people
are happy in New York before I let you
go to high heat ask him the poll
question that Rich Eisen show app
Brockman go forward yeah yeah Mad Dog
what's the worst contract in New York
sports the sports history Phil Jackson's
Dale Bobby Bonilla Alan Houston a rod
Darrelle Revis Wow not Revis you know
the Jackson contract does not involve a
cap so I wouldn't say him and Dolan's
got plenty of money so it doesn't hurt
the team because it doesn't involve
their salary cap so that would leave you
a rod Alan Houston
Alan Houston who's finally no longer
stand Bobby bo is still getting paid I
think through 2025 I save India I say
binya I know it's not a ton of money but
a-rod they want a championship and o9 he
helped him do it so you got to keep that
in mind I used to help them get to a
final made a big shot against Miami I
mean there was a little upside with
Houston he's a good guy
I got a got a ton of money but he's a
good guy definitely Binyah Binyah did
nothing for the Mets he was a mess at
the time that contact it's it hurt them
a lot as you said the million dollars a
year he gets every July so I'll say
Benny it's a good question I was good
poll question all right Thank You
Christopher appreciate Pat will chat
before your 3430 which I'm looking for
by 13 looking forward to goddess thanks
Chris that's Christopher Mad Dog Russo
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience
if you liked that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
move week six games to Saturday for that
wedding you have to go to